well if you watch cable news read the
Washington Post you know America has
only one enemy in the world it's called
Russia but the truth may be more
complicated than that the biggest threat
to this country is not Vladimir Putin
that's ludicrous
the biggest threat obviously is China
China spies on us more than any other
country it is behind the massive OPM
hack carried out from 2012 through 2014
it has of course the world's largest
population it will soon have the world's
largest economy its military is growing
rapidly in strength it even manufactures
most of the fentanyl that is killing
tens of thousands of Americans every
year Americans assume that this country
is on top and will be forever but could
we find ourselves overtaken before we
know it imminently even Michael
Pillsbury is a director for the Center
for training strategy at Hudson
Institute and one of the world's great
experts on this exact subject he's the
author of the hundred year marathon
trying to secret strategy to replace
America as the global superpower he
joins us tonight mr. pillsbury thanks
for coming on uh-huh thank you
so you've written I think the central
book on this question so we'll just
stipulate that what you say is true
because I think it's obviously true so
the question it which is China wants to
displace the United States as the most
powerful nation in the world why isn't
our leadership political media cultural
sounding the alarm on this because it's
happening well there's lots of pretty
good reasons lots of companies and
individuals have made large amounts of
money in China I hate to be so crass
about it but I have a colleague who
invested 200 million dollars six years
later he had two billion dollars in
return that can be a pretty big
motivator second you have inertia you
have the opening by Kissinger Nixon the
Bush family being very proud of their
connections with China you have this
almost a strong effort ten years ago to
set up g2 America and China together
would sort of rule the world that was
backed by Henry Kissinger's a big
Brzezinski Hank Paulson and quite a few
people think feel very strongly that the
US and China together can kind of
control the world I've had admirals and
generals tell me that they want to
cooperate with the Chinese military so
this good will feel
of cooperation with China is the way to
go that's still very strong I think that
explains also why President Trump has a
lot of pressure on him from the
bureaucracy from some in Congress not
all Chuck Schumer of all people supports
president Trump's tariffs for example
but this momentum is still there the
third thing is what I would call
intelligence failure the US intelligence
community's been wrong about several
major things from 1950 on and it looks
like understanding just how
sophisticated China was going to be in
ripping off our technology jobs
influencing our political system that
seems to have been gotten wrong I think
the intelligence community is back on
track now they're doing very well
but that also caused a kind of a
sluggishness in our response to China I
would say now we're much faster than
over the last six months or so a great
deal of change is taking place in the
u.s. understanding that China I hope
that's right so back to something you
said a second ago and I've heard people
say that that we can kind of share the
world stage share management of the
world with China is trying to have any
interest in sharing that with us you
know they turned us down several people
made these offers of the so-called g2
plan and the Chinese scholars who are
allowed to talk about it in articles and
books said no you know we really don't
want to be number two as a junior
partner with America so they're waiting
for later when I think they'll be number
one unless we take a lot of steps to
make it not happen we've got to deny
them technological supremacy that's the
first thing the second thing is we've
got to understand better how deeply
embedded they are in our companies in
our social life in our academic world we
really don't know we had a luxury with
the Russians of the Soviet Union was way
over there we didn't have much to do
with them they certainly didn't have any
massive business enterprises with us
China is deeply inside us and so we
don't want to demonize them totally we
caused problems in our own political
system but we've got to be more aware of
just how sophisticated they are well
we're spending the next month on the
special series on China
you will come back Michael Pillsbury for
that it's a can't think of a one quart
thank you I appreciate your coming on
tonight thank you